(upbeat music)
(crowd applauding)
- You, have y'all met before?
- Never, never but-
- No.
- You have reposted some of the vids,
like when I've been
playing you on the show.
- Oh well of course.
I mean, I'm honored-
- I was like, whoa.
- I always say like, you
made it if somebody like-
- Yeah, emulates you-
- Dresses up
for Halloween as you or
makes fun of you, so.
- Yeah.
No, I think you've made it
'cause you're in their mind.
You're in there, you do
impressions a lot though, right?
- Yes.
- And you did,
it's on SNL, you did Gwen?
- Yeah.
- I don't know that,
I have never seen this,
what's your Gwen impression?
- So I, you know, if No Doubt
comes on the radio or Gwen,
you come on the radio and I'm driving,
it is dangerous 'cause I
get so into your impression
and it's not safe, you
know, I can't drive.
I'm driving just like...
♪ For a long time I was
in love, beep, beep ♪
- Beep beep!
(all laughing)
Beep beep,
- And it's kind of that
old, I mean like the-
- Do that again, can you do it?
♪ You're really lovely underneath it all ♪
- I just love that song, it's my favorite.
(crowd cheering)
I love that.